vous avez vu la quantité qu'il ya dans
ma grosse marion contre l'habitude
journée au minimum de fabrice martin
ginette au menu aujourd'hui dans ce
restaurant de salive un sauté de veau à
la tomate confinement oblige un plat
proposé uniquement à emporter
la seule solution pour cette
restauratrice de continuer son activité
envisager de rester dans un canapé ou
d'un des traînées sur sur internet pour
trouver des aides je peux pas
l'envisager possible en temps normal
elle faire quotidiennement 25 couverts
en salle depuis le confinement cela se
limite entre 3 et 10 repas servis dans
ce qu'elle appelle une box de survie
mais pour elle le bénéfice n'est pas
vraiment financiers ça permet je dirais
de au moins de payer ma matière première
les sens
et puis ça m'occupe au lieu de dépenser
de l'argent dans des antidépresseurs
voilà j'ai mon antidépresseur naturel
qu'est la cuisine
autre exemple dans ce restaurant dit sur
ton cette semaine on a prévu un kit joue
de boeuf braisé au vin rouge accompagné
de lentilles diot de la région françois
la grue s'est lui aussi lancé dans la
vente à emporter
surtout pour ne pas rester loin de ses
fourneaux ces bandes de boxe se limite à
une trentaine par ce même là on va être
en dessous des 20% de ce qu'on doit
faire mais c'est vraiment psychologique
et puis faut être honnête ça paye aussi
une partie des frais n'a besoin de
trésorerie pour vivre donc ça il ya une
partie économique aussi si elle soulage
un peu les restaurateurs la vente à
emporter donc loin de compenser leur
perte de revenus